[Music]
one of the stunning findings showed up
in long-term meditators and this other
scientists were quite skeptical about
but Richard Davidson my co-author and
his group went ahead and tried it they
had people who had done you know a
thousand to ten thousand lifetime hours
of meditation come in and simply do a
retreat for one day in the lab and they
did a measure of the genes for
inflammation and they found that there
was a down regulation of inflammatory
genes from one day of meditation what
this means is that inflammation which is
at cause it's a risk factor for a wide
range of diseases you know diabetes
arthritis cancer cardiovascular disease
you name it inflammation almost always
plays a role in disease and what this
says is that intensive retreats in
meditation even for a day help you lower
the level of those genes we don't yet
know if this is clinically important
that's another study that needs to be
done but we do know that it's so
remarkable that people in genomic
science were amazed that a simple mental
exercise could have such a profound
impact on this array of genes but that's
pretty my opening there was a remarkable
finding when it comes to how the Olympic
level meditators experience pain
ordinarily if you bring someone into the
lab and you tell them we're going to
give you a burn in ten seconds it won't
cause blisters and your skin but you're
going to feel it it's going to hurt the
moment you tell them that the emotional
circuitry for feeling pain goes
ballistic it's as low layer of feeling
the pain already and then you give them
the touch of the hot test tube whatever
it is and it stays ballistic and then
for 10 seconds more it stays ballistic
they don't recover emotionally
the Olympic level meditators had quite a
different response you tell them you're
gonna get this feel is pain in ten
seconds their emotional centers don't do
anything they're completely equina me as
the pain comes and they feel it you see
it register physiologically but there's
no emotional reaction and there's no
emotional reaction afterward so in other
words they're totally equanimous they're
unflappable even though they experienced
the pain physiologically they don't have
the emotional reaction and what we find
is that calming the emotional reaction
is one of the most powerful benefits of
meditation and I'm not talking about the
Olympic level I'm talking about
beginners there's a wonderful method
called mindfulness based stress
reduction was developed by a friend of
ours Jon kabat-zinn years ago and it's
for people in hospitals people in
clinics although anyone can benefit but
one of the strongest findings on this
has been that it helps with people who
have chronic pain and I'm talking about
paying that medications not going to
help you with there's nothing medicine
knows what to do about this except give
you you know horrible narcotics that are
addictive and here is a very positive
alternative because what happens when
you do MBSR if you have chronic pain is
the emotional component changes you
shift your relationship to the pain it
no longer is my pain oh my god I can't
stand it instead it's oh there's that
sensation again
so the physiology of the pain continues
but the emotional component which is
really where the hurt is disappears or
is much reduced because you no longer
have that same relationship to the pain
that we do ordinarily
[Music]